I have experienced a lot of wild moments  in my life but I think tonight it's  probably topping all of them Colton  Haynes gets emotional while accepting  the Human Rights campaign's visibility  award in Seattle on Saturday night the  honor is given to celebrities who use  their elevated positions and reach to  benefit the LGBT community something the  28 year old actor takes pride in he  dedicated the award to the generations  of LGBTQ youth that come after him I  want to give them just a little more  courage to know that they're loved just  as they are that acceptance is something  haynes has struggled with personally the  actors sexuality was the focus of a lot  of fan speculation before finally coming  out publicly earlier this year  since then he has spoken openly about  his struggle with anxiety depression and  family hardship I'm asked to play so  many different roles as an actor I'm  sorry tonight I can actually be myself  for the first time it's feels incredible